♪♪
IT ALL COMES DOWN TO THIS.
VOTERS WILL DECIDE WHICH PARTY
WILL CONTROL CONGRESS AND THE
FUTURE DIRECTION OF OUR COUNTRY.
DEMOCRATS MAKING A LAST-DITCH
EFFORT TO STOP A POTENTIAL RED
WAVE THE PRESIDENT BIDEN TURNING
TO HIS FORMER BOSS BARACK OBAMA.
REPUBLICANS LOOKING TO
CAPITALIZE ON THEIR MOMENTUM.
DEMOCRATS CLOSING ARGUMENT IS
MUCH DIFFERENT THAN THE GOP'S
MORNING REPUBLICANS WILL DESTROY
THE COUNTRY.
>> ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTIONS OF OUR LIFETIME WILL
SHAPE OUR COUNTRY FOR DECADES TO
COME.
THE POWER TO SHAPE THAT OUTCOME
IS IN YOUR HANDS.
>> PEOPLE GET HURT.
IT HAS REAL CONSEQUENCES.
GOVERNMENTS START TELLING YOU
WHAT BOOKS YOU CAN READ AND
WHICH BOOKS YOU CANNOT.
DISSIDENTS START GETTING LOCKED
OUT.
REPORTER START GETTING LOCKED UP
IF THEY ARE NOT TELLING THE
PARTY LINE.
CORRUPTION RAINS BECAUSE THERE'S
NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SEEMS TO
THINK HIS PARTY WILL DEFY
HISTORY ON TUESDAY.
>> WE WILL WIN THIS TIME AROUND.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT OUR
CHANCES.
I THINK THAT WE WILL KEEP THE
SENATE AND PICK UP BUFFY CARED I
THINK WE HAVE A CHANCE OF
WINNING THE HOUSE.
I AM OPTIMISTIC.
>> MAKING IT A CHOICE, NOT A
REFERENDUM ON HIS RECORD.
A TOP DEMOCRAT DOES NOT SEE IT
THAT WAY.
>> HOW MUCH RESPONSIBILITY DO
YOU THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
FOR THIS POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT.
>> BASED ON ALL YOUR ANSWERS TO
ME IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU DON'T
BELIEVE DEMOCRATS DID ANYTHING
WRONG.
YOU BELIEVE IF YOU DON'T DO WELL
IT IS SIMPLY YOU HAD BAD
MESSAGING OR YOU DID NOT
COMMUNICATE AT RIGHT.
IS THAT YOUR BASIC TAKE HERE?
>> NEITHER YOU OR I KNOW WHAT
WILL HAPPEN ON TUESDAY SO WHAT
DO YOU SAY WE WAIT AND SEE.
>> SHOWING UP A LITTLE BIT.
ABC WASHINGTON POST OLD TODAY.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE THE EDGE ON
TURNOUT AND THE ECONOMY IS THE
ISSUE.
>> THAT DOES NOT SURPRISE ME.
I KNOW BARACK OBAMA WELL.
I NEVER MET HIM, ACTUALLY, I KNE
WAS EMBARRASSED YESTERDAY BY
HAVING TO CAMPAIGN FOR JOHN
FEDERMAN.
THERE IS SOMETHING CALLED
DIGNITY.
HE LOST A LITTLE DIGNITY
YESTERDAY.
HE HAD ALREADY SCHEDULED THIS
CAMPAIGN EVENT FOR FEDERMAN AND
THEN HE SAW THE DEBATE THAT WE
ALL SOLVE.
FOR A WHOLE HOUR.
MY SOURCES INSIDE ARE TELLING ME
THAT HE WANTED TO CANCEL THAT
DEBATE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GO THERE AND
CAMPAIGN FOR A GUY AFTER A
PERFORMANCE LIKE THAT.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN WORSE IF HE
HAD CANCELED.
FEDERMAN LOOKS LIKE -- HE HAS
MADE HIS ENTIRE CAREER OUT OF
EMPTYING THE PRISONS.
HE GETS THERE NT CANNOT TALK.
YOU CAN SEE BARACK OBAMA JUST
GOING LIKE THIS.
WHAT IS THIS GUY SAYING.
THEY DO THIS ON A SATURDAY IN
PHILADELPHIA.
1.5 MILLION POPULATION.
THEY GET OUT THERE AND THEY DO
5000 PEOPLE AT THE VENUE.
THEY ARE AT HALF CAPACITY.
THIS IS BARACK OBAMA, JOE BIDEN,
FEDERMAN.
TRUMP AND WAS DUE 17,000 IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT IS ABOUT POPULATION 6000.
THEY DOUBLED THE TOWN'S
POPULATION.
THAT IS DURING THE PHILLIES
GAME.
THAT WILL TELL YOU A LOT ABOUT
THE ENERGY.
THEN BARACK OBAMA COMES OUT AND
SAYS DISSIDENTS WILL BE LOCKED
UP.
I THINK THAT HE MEANT CRIMINALS.
AND THEN HE SAID WE WANT TO LOCK
UP REPORTERS.
TRUMP HAD BEEN PRESIDENT FOR
FOUR YEARS.
DID HE LOCK UP A SINGLE
REPORTER?
DO YOU THINK MITCH MCCONNELL
WILL LOCK UP REPORTERS?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THEY WILL BAN BOOKS.
NOW, I THINK THAT WE WILL BAN
THE BOOKS THAT TALK ABOUT
GRAPHIC SEX AND MIDDLE SCHOOL
LIBRARIES.
IF THAT IS HIS MESSAGE DURING A
CRIME CRISIS AND AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS, HE WILL GET CRUSHED.
>> THIS RACE IN PENNSYLVANIA IS
GAY AND.
WHAT ARE YOUR SOURCES INSIDE THE
OBAMA TEAM SAYING?
>> I THINK JESSE MAKES A GOOD
POINT ABOUT THE CROWD SIZE IN
THOSE THINGS.
THIS RACE IS A DEAD HEAT.
DURING THE DEBATE, I THINK ANY
OF US WANT HIM TO DO BETTER.
HE HAS HAD A STROKE AND WE WILL
HAVE A CHANCE TO SEE IF VOTERS
GIVE HIM THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT THERE.
WE DO NOT KNOW YET WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IN THE SENATE.
I THINK THE HOUSE IS LIKELY TO
GO REPUBLICAN.
RIGHT HEREIN NEW YORK YOU HAVE
SOME CLOSE RACES.
I THINK PHIL WAS ON THE OTHER
NIGHT SAYING VIRGINIA AS WHO WE
HAVE TO WATCH EARLY AND I THINK
WE SHOULD.
WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW OURSELVES TO
BE DISTORTED IF THE NUMBERS FOR
THE HOUSE JUMP UP EARLY.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS, I
HOPE THE RIGHT LESSONS ARE TAKEN
FOR WHOEVER WINS.
I CAN LIVE WITH THE OUTCOME.
IT WILL BE HARD TO LIVE WITH HIS
IF REPUBLICANS TAKE THE WRONG
LESSONS AND DEMOCRATS TAKE THE
WRONG LESSONS.
CRIME, EDUCATION, REPUBLICANS
OUGHT TO GIVE VOTERS A SENSE OF
SECURITY AROUND REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS.
WE HAVE TO WORK OUR HARDEST AND
TRY OUR HARDEST TO SECURE OUR
BORDER.
IF THEY ARE WILLING TO WORK
TOGETHER THERE, THE COUNTRY WILL
WIN.
IF BOTH SIDES TAKE THE WRONG
MESSAGE FROM IT, WHOEVER WINS
INTO EVER LOSES, IT WILL BE
ANOTHER TWO YEARS.
>> WHEN YOU BEEN CALLED A NAZI.
>> WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY.
>> YESTERDAY AT THE DEMOCRATS
EVENT, THEY SAID THAT THE
REPUBLICANS WILL SET OUR COUNTRY
BACK 50 YEARS.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT
BIDEN AND OBAMA COMING OUT IN
ALL OF THESE STATEMENTS THAT
THEY ARE MAKING ARE SO RICH IN
TERMS OF THE IRONY.
WHEN OBAMA STARTS TALKING ABOUT
REPORTERS BEING LOCKED UP, IF
THEY ARE NOT TELLING THE PARTY
LINE, I HAVE PULLED OUT A FEW
ARTICLES ON OBAMA'S WAR ON
JOURNALISTS WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
LEADING CONGRESS OVER THAT
INVESTIGATION OF JOURNALIST.
REMEMBER ALL OF THAT A FEW YEARS
AGO?
THAT IS RICH.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT ELSE IS
RICH.
CORRUPTION RAINS BECAUSE THERE
IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY WITH
REPUBLICANS.
HELLO, WHAT DO YOU THINK
HAPPENED WITH THE FBI, THE FALSE
DOSSIER AND ALL THE RE- UPPING
OF THAT.
THAT HAD TO DO WITH CORRUPTION.
AMERICANS HAVE HAD TWO YEARS OF
JOE BIDEN.
THEY CANNOT TAKE ANOTHER TWO
YEARS OF THIS.
AMERICANS HAVE TO BUY FOOD, GAS,
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING FORWARD TO
PAYING FOR THEIR ENERGY AND THEN
WHEN BIDEN COMES ALONG OR SEAN
PATRICK MALONEY IN THE 17TH IN
NEW YORK, COMING OUT AND SAYING
BIDEN IS SAYING HE IS FIXING OUR
ROADS AND BRINGING BACK JOBS
FROM CHINA, ARE YOU KIDDING?
HE IS SHUTTING DOWN COAL PLANTS
IN THE UNITED STATES, DANA AND
BUILDING THEM UP IN CHINA SO WE
CAN BUY OIL FROM CHINA.
AMERICANS ARE TOO SMART FOR THIS
NONSENSE.
THE FACT THAT JOE BIDEN IS NOT
THE CLOSER AND JOE BIDEN IS,
THAT IS TELLING.
>> KAMALA HARRIS WAS NOWHERE TO
BE SEEN.
SHE WAS ACTUALLY CAMPAIGNING IN
CALIFORNIA, IF THAT GIVES YOU AN
INDICATION OF HOW THINGS ARE
GOING.
PLUS WHAT HAPPENS TO THE HAPPY
ONE?
>> I DUNNO.
I'M JUST UNHAPPY I HAVE TO BE
HERE ON A SUNDAY.
I MEAN, LOOK.
TODAY WAS MY HEADSTART OF
DESTROYING DEMOCRACY.
WE WERE GOING TO GLUE OURSELVES
TO VOTING MACHINES.
I'M HERE ON THE FIVE DOING THIS
STUFF.
WE ARE ALL PART OF THE RIGHT
WING CONSPIRACY TO DESTROY
DEMOCRACY.
HONESTLY, I CANNOT WAIT TO GET
STARTED.
IF I VOTE, THEN I DESTROY
DEMOCRACY.
MAYBE I SHOULD NOT VOTE.
DOES THAT PRESERVE DEMOCRACY?
I THINK THAT WHAT WE ARE SEEING
IS, MAYBE WE ARE SEEING B AND
AIM FOR THE APOCALYPTIC
CAMPAIGNING.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT BIDEN
SAYING HE WILL PUT YOU ALL BACK
IN CHAINS.
WE THOUGHT THAT WAS BAD AND THEN
THEY FIND ANOTHER LEVEL AND THEN
ANOTHER LEVEL.
I DO NOT THINK THAT THEY CAN GET
MORE PAST THIS.
I THINK THAT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
IS FINALLY SEEING WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS PREDICT WILL HAPPEN
NEVER DOES.
ALMOST EVERYTHING THAT THEY SAY
THEN THEY ALSO REALIZE THAT
EVERYTHING THAT THE REPUBLICANS
WERE TALKING ABOUT ACTUALLY
MATTERS.
WHETHER IT'S INFLATION OR CRIME
OR IMMIGRATION.
WHAT EVER.
IT IS A BATTLE BETWEEN THE
IMAGINARY AND THE REAL.
THE REPUBLICANS IN THIS CASE, IT
IS REAL.
I AGREE WITH HAROLD THAT WE DO
SOME OF THE SAME THINGS.
WE WILL CALL ENTIRE PARTY
SOCIALISTS WHEN IT IS ONLY HALF
THE PARTY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT, HAROLD.
[LAUGHTER]
IT IS TERRIBLE.
TWO LAST POINTS, I WORRY IF YOU
KEEP SAYING RED WAVE, RED WAVE,
RED WAVE, A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL
NOT COME OUT.
I THINK THAT IT MAY BE A
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGY TO HAVE SUCH
LOW EXPECTATIONS THAT IT CANNOT
MEET THEM AND THEY WILL SEE THAT
IT IS NOT SO BAD.
>> WE WILL TRY TO KEEP THE SHOW
GOING.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO HELP ME
DESTROY DEMOCRACY?
I'VE GOT MY UNCLES PICKUP TRUCK.
WE WILL GO UP AND DOWN BROADWAY
AND JUST DESTROY DEMOCRACY.
>> I